hola maestros padres y estudiantes
soy sal de khan academy me emociona
anunciarles nuestros cursos de
preparación para grado escolar ustedes
ya conocen los cursos por grado de khan
academy en los que pueden trabajar a su
ritmo pero ahora tenemos esta forma para
que los estudiantes puedan asegurarse de
que van a llenar esas lagunas que puedan
tener en el camino a alcanzar el nivel
de grado en estos cursos de preparación
para grado escolar los estudiantes
comienzan desde lo más básico pero
avanzan rápidamente por los temas que ya
conocen y les ayudan a identificar sus
lagunas en las cosas que aún no saben de
esta manera cuando vuelvan a la escuela
estarán preparados de forma óptima para
trabajar el nivel de su grado escolar y
más allá